[Music]
all right ready for takeoff
[Music]
hello snapchat drone
or flying camera or whatever the company
calls you
okay come back to me flying selfie stick
[Music]
good job this is the new 230 dollar snap
pixie it's not exactly a drone but it's
also kind of a drone it's designed to
work with the snapchat app though you
can download the photos and videos and
share them to anywhere you'd like
but here's the really unique thing about
the pixie you don't fly it it's
autonomous which is kind of scary but
also kind of nice for someone like me
who's been scared of learning how to fly
a drone but it's also pretty limited and
oof the battery life
let's see how this thing works
there are two cameras on the pixie the
one pointed at the ground is used to
stabilize the drone and detect your hand
aka its landing pad the camera facing
outward identifies where you are and
captures better than hd video flying the
thing couldn't be any easier you set it
to one of four flying modes hold it out
so it's at eye level check for the green
ready light and press this button it
takes off and the software then tracks
the location of your head and body so it
knows where you are and when to come
back to you the pixie won't fly higher
than about 15 feet up and 30 feet away
from you just watch out for the trees it
doesn't have obstacle avoidance
oh no
in the app you can set the length of
recording up to 60 seconds per clip so
back to those four flight patterns hover
because well
it hovers reveal because it reveals more
of the scene follow because it is
supposed to follow you i'm over here
come on and then there's orbit as it
orbits around you
the quality is eh it's fine in bright
light but everything looks grainy and
compressed also there's no microphone so
no audio is recorded at all for this
video we used a microphone and synced
the audio afterwards is this thing on
but the pixi's small size has some big
downsides i've been lucky if i could get
one battery to last more than three
minutes of flying which was often just
three to four flights snap says you
should get five to eight flights with
the default flight durations you can buy
extra batteries for twenty dollars or
this dual charger with two batteries for
fifty dollars then there's the fact that
the pixie weighs less than a quarter
pound just a bit more than a bag of
actual pixie sticks i used to eat so
many of these as a kid the issue with
that lightweight
wind snap says it works best when wind
speeds are below 7 miles per hour
speaking of safety while the pixie is
very small and flies very low it's still
technically classified as a drone in the
u.s that means you need to abide by the
national state and local laws i passed
the faa's recreational safety test and
checked its before you fly app before
flying in any location
and if you don't want to deal with all
that maybe just fly in your house
be safe
the footage is recorded on the pixi's
internal 16 gigabytes of storage and
will send to your snapchat app when
paired via bluetooth in the app there is
a new auto crop tool which takes the
pixies native horizontal video and
automatically crops it vertically for
posting you can also do all that fun
snapchat stuff
i've had a lot of fun taking snaps with
this little thing but it doesn't really
do much more than take photos of you and
in that way it's not really that much
more than a glorified selfie stick
in fact another company called air
selfie is just leaning into that idea
the air neo is even smaller and lighter
than the pixie which means i know you
hate the wind
you hate the wind you tiny drones hate
the wind the 150 air neo will start
shipping in a couple of weeks the snap
pixie will start at 230 dollars but will
only be available online in limited
quantities so yeah i guess this is
becoming a thing easy to use autonomous
mini drones that follow us around
just don't go out in the wind or without
a fanny pack full of batteries
there's so many different ways you can
wear this thing like you can wear it
like a necklace like an old school
camera or like a
purse
[Music]
you